STAY. OKAY WELL GOOD AFTERNOON
WAY FOR MORE MEMBERS TO ARRIVE
BEFORE WE- STOPS A QUORUM- BUT-
AND SOME AUTHORS AT THAT AS
WELL- BUT- FANTASTIC- BUT WITH
THAT I WANT TO- OPEN THE MEDIAN
IN START WITH SOME LOGISTICS AND
SUPPORT CALLS YOU KNOW FIRST-
YOU FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT ARE PRESENT IN THIS
ROOM- WE ARE REQUIRING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE IN- PLEASE FOLLOW THE-
THE DIRECTIONS OF OUR SERGEANTS-
AND POSTED GUIDANCE. THERE ARE
SEVEN BILLS ON OUR AGENDA- THAT-
ARE GONNA BE SOME CONSIDERED BY
OUR COMMITTEE GO TO A WHICH ARE
PROPOSED AS PART OF OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR I BELIEVE AN ADDITIONAL
ITEM HAS BEEN REMOVED AS WELL
RIGHT ITEM NUMBER THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG. I AM FOR
EACH ITEM ON OUR AGENDA THERE
WILL BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT COMMENTS MAY BE
MADE IN PERSON IN THIS ROOM OR
BY PHONE A PUBLIC COMMENT WILL-
HAVE A LIMIT OF TEN MINUTES FOR
EACH BILL. THIS AFTERNOON. THE
PHONE NUMBER TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS WILL BE SHOWN OR
PROVIDED TO OUR VIEWERS ON
SCREEN. THROUGHOUT THE HEARING-
THE PHONE NUMBER IS ALSO POSTED
ON OUR SIMPLY COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
OF FOR ALL OF THOSE WHO- WILL BE
MAKING SOME COMMENTS THIS
AFTERNOON. WE ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME. AND IF
APPLICABLE THE ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT AND IF YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THE BILL THAT IS UNDER.
THE CONSIDERATION. ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC IS ALSO WELCOME TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN COMMENTS. TO OUR
COMMITTEE THROUGH EMAIL EMAILS
MAY BE SENTTO THE ADDRESS FOUND
ON OUR WEBSITE- WHICH IS A G. R.
I. DOT COMMITTEE. C. O. M. M. I.
T. T. E. ASSEMBLY DOT C. A. DOT
G. OVIH. IN ORDER TO FACILITATE
THE GOAL OF HEARING AS MUCH FROM
THE PUBLIC WITHIN THE LIMITS OF
OUR TIME WE WILL NOT PERMIT
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS. DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF OUR PROCEEDING. UP
PLEASE BE AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS
OF THESE RULES MAY SUBJECT YOU
TO REMOVAL. OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
A PROCESS BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY. AND SO WITH
THAT. WE WILL- WAIT HERE
PATIENTLY TELL MORE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ARRIVE IN SOME OF
OUR AUTHORS. WHO ARE. A
SCHEDULED TO PRESENT BILLS
ARRIVE AS WELL THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF YOU'RE READY
TO GO WE ARE WE ARE WRITING
THEMSELVES QUORUM BUT PLEASE.
NOT YET BUT WE CAN TAKE IT UP
ONCE- ONCE WE DO. SO WELCOME TO
OUR COMMITTEE. AND SO WE ARE
READY WHEN YOU ARE SOME OF THEM. BOB.
AS CHAIR AB ADVANTAGES OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT. SEVENTY
SEVENTY THREE THE WILLIAMSON ACT
WAS CREATED IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE TO PRESERVE OPEN SPACE AND
CONSERVE AGRICULTURAL LAND FOR
YEARS THE STATE FUNDED THE ACT
AT AROUND THIRTY FIVE TO FORTY
MILLION TO ALLOW CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO ENTER INTO
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LANDOWNERS TO
OFFER PROPERTY TAX INCENTIVES IN
EXCHANGE FOR RESTRICTED USE OF
THE LAND. ALTHOUGH THIS FUNDING
CEASED DURING THE RECESSION THE
BILL BEFORE YOU AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY THREE SEEKS TO REINSTATE
THIS FUNDING BY ALLOCATING FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO THE WILLIAMSON ACT FOR
THE PURPOSE OF SUBVENTION
PAYMENTS. THESE PAYMENTS HAVE
ALLOWED FOR THE PROTECTION OF
SIXTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION ACRES
OR NEARLY ONE THIRD OF PRIVATELY
OWNED LAND IN CALIFORNIA. SINCE
IT HAS NOT BEEN REENACTED MANY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO ACCEPT NEW CONTRACTS.
FOR LAND CONSERVATION
ADDITIONALLY SOME COUNTIES HAVE
ISSUED NON RENEWAL NOTICES TO
LANDOWNERS THAT HAD ALREADY BEEN
GIVEN A CONTRACT THIS MEANS
LANDS THAT COULD OTHERWISE BE
CONSERVE OUR AT RISK FOR
DEVELOPMENT. AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY THREE WILL BENEFIT ALL
CALIFORNIANS BY KEEPING LAND
WORKING AND VALUABLE SPACE OPEN
FOR AGRICULTURE AND WILDLIFE
THAT DEPEND UPON IT. HI HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS TAYLOR
RUSSIAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION AND CATHERINE
FREEMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. I
THINK IS ON THE NUMBER THAT YOU
GUYS WOULD LIKE TO. HOW DOES ONE
. MY NAME IS KATHERINE FREEMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND ALSO FOR THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
THREE AND THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR CARRYING THE BILL. AS
YOU HEARD THE WILLIAMSON ACT IS
A STATE ESTABLISHED PROGRAM.
OTHER PRESERVES AGRICULTURE AND
OPEN SPACE THROUGH PROPERTY TAX
INCENTIVES PRIVATE LANDOWNERS IN
EXCHANGE FOR A LOWER PRIVATE
PROPERTY TAXES ENTERED INTO
ROLLING TEN AND TWENTY YEAR
CONTRACT. COMMITMENTS WITH
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES- TO KEEP
THEIR LAND IN AGRICULTURAL A
COMPATIBLE LAND USE. THE
WILLIAMSON ACT IS BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE IT'S PRESERVED OVER
SIXTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION ACRES
OF AGRICULTURE AND WORKING
LANDS. THE TAX RELIEF THAT THE
CONTRACTS PROVIDE EVEN MORE
ENTICING BENEFITS TO KEEPING. WE
WORKING OPEN SPACE AND CONTINUE
AS A SPACE FOR WILDLIFE AND
AGRICULTURE THAT DEPEND ON THEM
AND THEN THEY COUNTIES AND TOWNS
THAT DEPEND ON THESE
AGRICULTURAL AREAS. MORE THAN
EVER- OPEN SPACES NEEDED FOR
MULTIPLE BENEFITS WATER FARMING
RANGELAND FOOD SUPPLY. WILLIAMS
AND I WAS ALWAYS INTENDED TO BE
A PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE
COUNTY IS IN EXCHANGE FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE A PROGRAM. WITH
THE GOAL OF FARMING AND LAND
PRESERVATION OR TO RECEIVE A
PARTIAL REPLACEMENT OF WORK ON
PROPERTY TAX AND THESE TAXES
WERE JUST USE FOR AGRICULTURE
THERE WERE USED FOR THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY. THE FOREGOING
PROPERTY TAXES COULD HAVE BEEN
USED FOR PUBLIC SAFETY SCHOOLS
AND OTHERS. SIX A MENTIONS WERE
ONE OF THE CALIFORNIA'S RURAL
COUNTIES FEW DISCRETIONARY
REVENUE SOURCES AND THEIR LOSS
TODAY. UNTIL IT WAS ELIMINATED
IN THE TWENTY EIGHT TWO THOUSAND
NINE AND TEN STATE BUDGET.
WILLIAM SNACK FUNDING. RANGED
FROM AS YOU HEARD THIRTY FIVE TO
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS. MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR. AND AS WE MOVE
INTO ANOTHER UNPRECEDENTED
BUDGET SURPLUS YEAR. THE
SUBVENTIONS ARE EVEN MORE THAN
IMPORTANT THAN EVER. WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT REVIVING STATE
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM IS A
COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO PRESERVE.
AGRICULTURAL AND OPEN SPACE
LANDS AND RESTORE COUNTY
SPENDING THANK YOU. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
TAYLOR RUSSIAN WITH A CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU WE'RE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
THREE FOR ALL THE REASONS THAT
WERE SEATED BUT I WANTED TO
OFFER. A LITTLE BIT MORE IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE WHEN ONE'S
NECK WAS PASSED IT WAS. BASED
SOLELY ON OPEN SPACE AND ACKLIN
PRESERVATION AND THAT ACTUALLY
HAS ITS VALUES AND WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED OF KEEP
KEEPING FARMERS FARMING. I THINK
THE CHALLENGE SINCE THE LOSS OF
SUBVENTIONS HAS BEEN ABOUT
ARTICULATING. THE BENEFITS OF A
TWENTIETH CENTURY PROGRAM IN
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY CONTEXT- SO
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT WILLIAMS
NOT CONTRACTED LAND HIT ALL THE
MARKERS THAT ARE PRIORITIES FOR
THIS ADMINISTRATION. HOPEFULLY
FOR THIS LEGISLATURE AND FOR THE
PUBLIC- ANY ADDITIONAL DECREASE
COSTS FOR FARMERS THE ON KEEPING
FARMERS FARMING. ALLOW THEM TO
REINVEST IN THOSE PRIORITIES AND
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND THINGS
LIKE AIR QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
WITH DUST MANAGEMENT TECHNIQUES.
ARE PROTECTING AND ENHANCING
BIODIVERSITY THROUGH HABITAT
RESTORATION FOR JOB
OPPORTUNITIES AUTHORIZING PUBLIC
ACCESS ON THE WINGS NOT
CONTRACTED LAND SO WE CAN HAVE
EQUAL ACCESS TO NATURE- ENHANCED
IN ORGANIZED LAND USE.
FACILITATING CLIMATE CHANGE
MITIGATION AND ADAPTATION ON
FARM- ANNE'S COMPATIBLE USES
THAT ARE BENEFICIAL FOR THE
STATE LIKE RENEWABLE ENERGY
GENERATION. SO WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THAT COUNTIES
CONTINUE TO INVEST AND ALLOW FOR
AND LANDS TO BE UNDER CONTRACT.
AND SUBVENTIONS DO MATTER JUST
YESTERDAY IMPERIAL COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS HEARD A MOTION TO
TRY AND- OPEN UP. ACREAGE FOR
WINGS NOT CONTRACTS AND WAS
DENIED BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY CAN'T
AFFORD IT WITHOUT THE SUBVENTION
PAYMENTS ARE OFFERED SO. WE DO-
VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE INTENTION
OF SEVENTEEN SEVENTY THREE AND
HOPE. THAT WE HEAR AND I WOULD
SAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THAT TEST. WE DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES ON FILE IN OPPOSITION.
SO THIS TIME ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SEE NON. YEAH BUT
THIS ONE SAY MOVE THE BILL AND
THE OPERATOR ADDIS'S- OF COURSE
OF COURSE SO OF COURSE SO STILL
WAITING FOR ONE MORE MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE TO ESTABLISH
QUORUM ABOUT WITH THAT WE'LL GO
TO SOME PUBLIC COMMENT SO IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE-
ROOM- WILLING TO OFFER SOME. THE
PUBLIC ON THIS BILL NOW THE TIME
DO SO. SEE NOW WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES OPERATE ARE YOU WITH
US. YES AMERICA. DO WE HAVE ANY
CALLERS IN THE QUEUE TO OFFER
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE SEVEN SEVEN THREE.
ENDANGERMENT IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS
FOR BILL ONE SEVEN SEVEN THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE
ZERO TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS. HOW WE DO OF THE LOOKS LIKE TO
IN OUR QUEUE TO JUST BE A MOMENT.
YEAH WILL FIRST GO TO LINE
NUMBER ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE
SHATTERED FROM CHRISTIANITY'S
KLEIN ON BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO
COUNTY BOARD AB SEVENTY SEVEN
THREE THANK YOU. X. WE HAVE
NUMBER THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
MADELINE COOPER FROM THE OPEN
MARKET MORE ON BEHALF OF YELLOW
COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IMASSAGER THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. THANK YOU
ND SO WITH THAT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REALLY APPRECIATE- THE
BILL AND WE'LL TAKE IT UP AS
SOON AS WE STEPS CORE. RESHAPE
THAT THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. SO- YEAH. CONNECTS WE
WILL BE TAKING UP ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO FOUR ONE TWO. BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AB APPALOOSA THE APPROVAL
SO CARLOS ARE SOME NUMBER
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
OKAY THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS AB
TWENTY FOUR TWELVE WILL CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA SMALL
FARMERS SAVE WATER REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
CURRENTLY THE SUSTAINABLE WATER
EFFICIENCY AND HEALTH CARE
PROGRAMS. SWEEP CURRENTLY
PILOTED BY CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURAL HAS
HELPED HUNDREDS OF FARMERS SAVE
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
ACRE FEET OF WATER AND REDUCES
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND METRIC TON.
OF CO TWO ACROSS A HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN ACRES. FURTHER
WATER SAVINGS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS CAN BE GAINED BY
RECLAIMING IRRIGATION WATER.
RECLAIMED IRRIGATION CAN BE.
REUSED TO IRRIGATE CROPS
RECHARGE GROUNDWATER OR BE
TRANSFERRED TO OTHER USERS
DOWNSTREAM WHILE REDUCING CO TWO
AB TWENTY FOUR TWELVE X. EXTENDS
THE SWEET PROGRAM TO SUPPORT
SMALL FARMERS AND RECLAIMING A
STRONG IRRIGATION RUNOFF WITH ME
TODAY IS CHARLES BURKE PROFESSOR
AND CHAIRMAN OF THE IRRIGATION
TRAINING AND RESEARCH CENTER AT
CAL POLY. AT SAN LUIS OBISPO AND
JIM CLEAR FOUNDER OF IRRIGATION
DEALERS ASSOCIATION. THEY GIVE
THEM THE NUMBER PLEASE. YES SO
BOTH OF THE SPEAKERS WILL BE
CALLING AND THEY SHOULD BE ON
THE LINE. AND TASK I GUESS WE
WILL START- OPERATOR IF YOU'RE
WITH US- ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FOUR
ONE TWO TESTIMONY BY CHARLES
BURT. I DO NOT SHOW THAT CHARLES
IS DIALED IN AS YET. OKAY DO WE
HAVE A JIM CLAIRE. I WOULD
CHANGE COLOR IS ON THE LINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN- THANK THANK THANK
YOU- I'VE BEEN INVITED TO THE
MEETING I HAVE SOME IDEA OF WHAT
WE'RE HERE TO DO I CAN TELL YOU
THAT- MY COMPANY IS IN THE-
BUSINESS OF. YOUR GAUGE DESIGN
ENGINEERING AND CONSTRUCTION.
ALL SORTS OF ROW CROPS AND TREES
AND VINES- AND OTHER THINGS FIVE
STOCK ISSUES AND- ALL MANNERS OF
IRRIGATION AND WE'RE IN THE
NORTHERN SAN JOAQUIN IN SOUTHERN
SACRAMENTO VALLEY- SMALL FARMS-
ARE ARE HAVE USED AND YOU BONTA
LADY IN FACT THE PROGRAMS OVER
THE YEARS- YOU KNOW FARMERS ARE
A CONSERVATIONIST AND- ARE VERY
CONSCIOUS OF WAYS. AND POLLUTION
AND THAT SORT OF THING AND SOME
OF THE SOME OF THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS AVAILABLE AS
WELL AS SOME OF THE OLDER
TECHNOLOGIES IT IS VERY
EXPENSIVE AND TEDIOUS TO INSTALL
AND DESIGN- THESE PROGRAMS ARE
REALLY WORKED WELL- AND- YOU
KNOW WHETHER. AND I HAVE NEVER
SEEN- ALWAYS BEEN ANY IN ARCADIA
WE- ARE GOING TO THE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT- THAT COME ALONG
EVERY EVERY ONCE IN AWHILE. THE
TEMPORARILY BUT- OUR OUR OUR A
COMPANY SERVES FINALLY SMALL
FARMERS ARE PROBABLY ONE OF THE
LARGEST PROVIDERS IN IN
CALIFORNIA'S FOR THE NUMBER OF-
CLIENT THE FARM THAT WE SERVED
AS OPPOSED TO LARGE ACREAGES
THAT WE GET SOME LARGE ACREAGES
BUT WE MOSTLY TALKED VERY ON THE
SMALL. FAMILY FARMER CLOSELY
HELD FARM- AND- GOOD NIGHT
STOCKTON AREA WERE BASED YOU
KNOW THERE IS A OF A LOT OF
WATER BUT IT BRINGS DOWN THE-
SIDE WITH THEIR- YEAH. WE- I
REALLY FEEL LIKE THAT D. THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY OVER THE YEARS-
IN THE WAY THESE- THESE PROGRAMS
ARE USED AS IF THEY AFFECTS ONE
AND I'M NOT I'M A CONSERVATIVE-
FINANCIAL TYPE PERSON. THE BARS
GOVERNMENT AND I WOULD SET A
LAKE- I THINK THE THREE PROGRAM
PROBABLY DESERVES. A LITTLE
MORE- CLARIFICATION ON HOW IT
WORKS AND WHY BECAUSE IT IS. A
LITTLE BIT CONFUSING. AND- THE
PROBABLY NEEDS A LITTLE. BIT
MORE ENERGY AS FAR AS HOW IT SO
HOW IT SO ORGANIZED AND- AND
PUBLICIZED. THE END WORKING AND
WE'RE VERY WE'RE VERY EXPERIENCE
AT ALL WITH ALL THE NRCS
PROGRAMS AB BUT NOT SO MUCH BUT
WE DO WE HAVE WE HAVE HELP
GROWERS APPLIED IN NEW VIDEO
FUND THAT ALL WAS REQUIRED
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY- AND OPERATOR IS
MISTER BIRD. ON THE LINE. YES
OKAY SO MR BURKE- IF YOU- CAN
OPERATE AS MANY BE GREAT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. OKAY GREAT YEAH MY
NAME IS CHARLES BURKE I'M A
PROFESSOR EMERITUS OF IRRIGATION
AT CAL POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO. AND
I WAS THE FOUNDER AND THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE IRRIGATION
TRAINING AND RESEARCH CENTER THE- THE ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
PORT TWENTY FOUR TWELVES I REDID
IT DRESSES UP- MORE COMPLETE
VISION OF IMPROVED AGRICULTURAL
MANAGEMENT- THEN- WHAT WAS
HISTORICALLY DONE WITH SWEET- S.
WE'VE PROVIDED- INVESTMENTS AND
THINGS LIKE SOIL MOISTURE
MONITORING BUT- THOSE CAN BE
HELPFUL TO FARMERS AND THEY'VE
BEEN WIDELY ACCEPTED BUT THERE
REALLY ISN'T MUCH DOCUMENTATION.
IN BASIN WIDE- WATER SAVING- HI
I STRONGLY ENDORSE A PROGRAM
THAT REQUIRES SPECIFICATIONS AND
SOLID DOCUMENTATION OF ACTUAL
IMPROVEMENTS IN PERFORMANCE OF
ALL KINDS NOT DESCRIPTION OTHER
SPRINKLER DRIP MICRO IN SERVICE
YOU'RE GAUGING. AND ONE THING TO
CONSIDER IS. REQUIRING A
STANDARDIZED IRRIGATION SYSTEM
EVALUATIONS BEFORE AND AFTER AT
LEAST ON A SAMPLING OF THE FIELD
SEXY DOCUMENT FORMS. STATE THE
OTHER THING THAT THAT I DIDN'T
SEE WHICH IS NOT TOO WELL
UNDERSTOOD IS THAT. IT
CALIFORNIA REALLY HAS TO GET BY
WITH THE- WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
GET BY WITH LESS WATER BUT WE
WANT TO ACHIEVE THE SAME OR MORE
PRODUCTION AND THAT REQUIRES A
MORE. SYSTEMATIC LOOK AT THINGS.
OUT ONE OF THE BEST COMPLIMENTS
OF THAT IS. TO GAUGE IN THAT
YEAR APPLICATION OF FERTILIZERS
THE WATER. THERE ARE SOME
EXCELLENT EQUIPMENT EXCELLENT
CHEMICALS- EXCELLENT COMPANY
SORRY SPECIALIZED IN THAT BUT
IT'S STILL IN ITS INFANCY AND
THAT'S- I THINK WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO REALLY MAKE SOME MAJOR
CHANGES IN WATER USE EFFICIENCY.
IN CALIFORNIA- IF YOU MEASURE
PRODUCTION PER UNIT OF WATER
CONSUMED. SO I'D YOUR SEATS. WE
DEVELOP- PARTY FRANK PROGRAMS
EDUCATIONAL AEROSMITH ARE
PROPERLY FUNDED THEY COULD
REALLY BE A GREAT EXCEPT EXCEPT
FOR THE- THAT THIS BILL. AND THE
ALSO WE'VE DEVELOPED TECHNICAL
SPECIFICATIONS AYE AND LIKE I
SAY I THINK THAT'S THE KIND OF
THING YOU NEED TO HAVE A STRONG
PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER BYRD FOR YOUR TESTIMONY-
WE DON'T HAVE ANY OPPOSITION OR
REGISTER OPPOSITION ON FILE. SO
AT THIS TIME IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NOW THE TIME ASK. C.
NINE WILL MOVE TO- PUBLIC
COMMENT TO ANYONE IN THIS ROOM-
WILLING OR THAT HAS- SOME
COMMENTS TO MAKE ON THIS BILL.
PLEASE AVOID OBSCENE NINE. OUT
WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR WE HAVE CALLERS IN THE
QUEUE FOR ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FOUR
ONE TWO. AND TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENTS FOR AB TWO FOUR ONE TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS. THIS YEAR WE DO HAVE
ONE IN OUR QUEUE THEY'LL JUST BE
A MOMENT.
THEN WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS MONEY FOUNDER AMOK FORMER
GORE AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
REGION HERE. ALL NON OUR- LOCAL
CORPORATE AB ONE TO BILL- AND
EXTEND THIS WEEK'S PROGRAM.
HELPS PROVIDE THOSE FARMERS TO-
THANK YOU BECOME MORE AND- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- OPERATOR ANY OTHER
BECAUSE THE Q. AT THE TIME WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. A
TASK SO WITH THIS- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YOU LIKE CLOSE UP I JUST
LIKED HER RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. IT DOESN'T REALLY BE SHE
YOU- AUTHORING THIS LEGISLATION
I'VE SEEN YOU KNOW HAVING BEEN
ON ON ON ON US MEDICAL TO IS
ACROSS THE STATE I'VE SEEN THE
BENEFITS OF THE YOU KNOW THIS
WEEK PROGRAM AS WE KNOW IT'S
BEEN OVERPRESCRIBED- YOU KNOW
THROUGH- OUR STATE SO- REALLY
APPRECIATE- YOU CHAMPION IN
THIS. EFFORT THANK THOUGH AND SO
WITH THAT WE THOUGHT NOT A
STATUS QUORUM BOOK WE WILL TAKE
THIS BILL UP WHEN WE DO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT
AND SO I KNOW WE HAVE ANOTHER
AUTHOR IN THE ROOM. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG. HERE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL- ONE SIX SEVEN
EIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WELCOME
TO ASSEMBLY AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE. AND WE ARE READY WHEN
YOU ARE. A GOOD AFTERNOON AS
CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH WILL CONVENE
A PANEL OF EXPERTS UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE TO PROVIDE
REPRESENTATION AND SOLUTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY A MESS A HISTORIC
SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS CALIFORNIA'S
FARMERS HAVE BEEN HIT HARD FROM
THE DROUGHT THE PANDEMIC
WILDFIRES AND NOW THE MOST
RECENT BACKLOG AT THE PORTS
WHICH HAS IMPOSE MORE OBSTACLES
FOR WORLD RENOWNED AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY. THEY HAVE LOST AN
ESTIMATED TWO POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN EXPORT SALES BETWEEN
MAY AND SEPTEMBER LAST YEAR DUE
TO PORT CONGESTIONS AND THEY'RE
SEEING AN ESTIMATED 20%
REDUCTION IN EXPORT
OPPORTUNITIES. WELL THE FOCUS
EVERY SENSE SOLUTIONS HAS BEEN
ON OUR COAST SUPPORTS FARMERS
ARE LEFT WITHOUT VIABLE EXPORT
OPPORTUNITIES AS YOU ALL KNOW-
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY IS A GLOBAL LEADER
DESPITE SOME OF THE MOST
STRINGENT. REGULATIONS ALL WHILE
CONTINUING TO INNOVATE AND PUT
FOOD ON OUR TABLES SO WHEN THEY
STRUGGLE WE NEED TO ACT. THE
ISSUES FACING FARMERS ARE UNIQUE
PRODUCE IS GROWN FURTHER INLAND
AND HAS A SHELF LIFE AND SO WHEN
THERE ARE SHIPPING DELAYS
FARMERS CANNOT RECOVER LOST
PRODUCE. THIS BILL WOULD CREATE
A BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION MADE UP
OF EXPERTS IN THE AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
ON CHANGES THAT NEED TO OCCUR TO
MITIGATE THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS.
OF POOR CONGESTION HAS HAD ON
AGRICULTURAL COMMODITIES.
CONVENING A PANEL OF EXPERTS
WILL HELP LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL POLICYMAKERS IMPLEMENT
NECESSARY FORMS. I'M JOINED BY
SHARING BECAUSE ALL THOSE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY BAKERSFIELD I
WAS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPO
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS. THE DALLAS
THREE MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE.
SHURIKENS ALL THIS YEAR ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BAKERSFIELD ONE AT THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG FOR
INTRODUCING THIS LEGISLATION.
BAKERSFIELD HAS THE LARGEST CITY
IN KERN COUNTY REALLY DEPENDS ON
THE AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY IS ONE
OF OUR KEY ECONOMIC DRIVERS- HAS
MENTIONED FARMERS HAVE REALLY
GROWN ACCUSTOMED TO HAVING TO
PIVOT THEIR BUSINESS MODELS IN
ORDER TO. ACCOUNT FOR ONGOING
DROUGHT LACK OF WATER
ALLOCATIONS AND WILDFIRE
MITIGATION AND- THE PANDEMIC
REALLY BROUGHT LIGHT TO A NEW
ISSUE AND THAT'S THAT OF PORT
CONGESTION AND HOW IT AFFECTS
GOODS MOVEMENT- SO BY CREATING A
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION WILL
REALLY CREATE A PLATFORM FOR
IDENTIFYING INEFFICIENCIES BEST
PRACTICES AND RECOMMENDATIONS SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO SUSTAIN CALIFORNIA'S-
ROBUST AGRICULTURAL. INDUSTRY
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
TESTIMONY MS GONZALEZ ND AT
THIS TIME- WE'RE GOING TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM. SO MADAM
SECRETARY CAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. JERRY VERSUS HERE. MATHIS
AGUIAR-CURRY CUNNINGHAM LARA
GRAY IRWIN. JONES SAWYER LEVINE
WE HAVE A RAW. WOOD NEVER SO
GETTING BACK TO US ON THE BILL-
ONE SIX SEVEN EIGHT. AND THEIR-
THERE'S NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME SO ANY MEMBERS OF
THE CAN HAVE QUESTIONS AS TIME
ASK. C. NINE WE WILL MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT- WILL OPEN UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR- COMMENTS
MADE IN THIS ROOM. RIGHT HI.
CHRIS OKAY YES ALL RIGHT SO MY
NAME IS CARLA CABRAL AND I AM
HERE WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE ARE YOU HERE TO- I'M
HERE TO TALK TO YOU ALL AND THIS
IS A TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
EXACTLY YES THIS IS A DEFINITELY
A PUBLIC COMMENT OKAY SO WE
HAVE- SO THERE'S PROCESS AND SO
ABSOLUTELY- THE ONLY THING WE'RE
ACCEPTING IS A IF YOU SUPPORT
THE BILL OR OPPOSE THIS LIPPIES
LEGISLATION AND IT'S DONE FROM
THE MICROPHONE I UNDERSTAND THAT
AND I WANT TO SAY THAT I WAS
VERY EXCITED TO COME HERE TODAY.
IN ORDER TO BE PART OF A
HISTORIC VOTE ON THE FACTORY
FARM MORATORIUM BILL AB TWENTY
SEVEN THAT'S NOT THE FOR THAT'S
NOT ON OUR END THAT DEAL HAS
BEEN COMPLETELY RE WRITTEN DUE
TO PRESS. HI THIS OKAY SO AT
THIS TIME- AT THIS TIME. WE'RE
CONTINUING TO TAKE TESTIMONY
FOR. A CENTER FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
. ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE SIX SEVEN
EIGHT. YOU YEAH YEAH NO MORE
BACK REFORMS FEELS. HAPPY IN HER
AND I'M HERE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT HAPPENS BASSES CALIFORNIANS
. IN ORDER SUPPORT BACKGROUND AS
A PARENT MARC. AND WE SAW IT
THIS TIME MA'AM THAT IS NOT ON
THE AGENDA THAT BILL. YEAH. SO
THIS OUR COMMITTEE WILL TAKE A
RECESS FIVE MINUTES.
BECAUSE THE BLOOD TO A RUMBLE IS
BUILT AROUND HIS CAMERA. OKAY SO
I THINK WHAT I'LL DO IS I'LL
JUST. PRESENT AT TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED FOR SOMEONE OR ARAMBULA
AND THEN WE WILL HOPEFULLY HAVE
SOMETHING UP AND ABOUT. IT'S.
BOB HERTZBERG AND WALDRON. WHAT
TO GOTHROUGH. MISTER CHAIR WHEN
YOU ARE READY- TO PRESENTS AB.
TWO FIVE ZERO ZERO ARAMBULA GO
AHEAD THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA NOTES SAID HE IS
PLEASED TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE OFFERED- AND SO-
GINGER IS A MOTION AND A MOTION
A SECOND SO VERY QUICKLY THIS
LEGISLATION ESTABLISHES THE
FARMHOUSE WILL PILOT PROJECT
WHICH WOULD SUPPORT HOSPITALS
MAKING THE TRANSITION TO BUY
CALIFORNIA SOURCE AGRICULTURE
PRODUCTS TO PATIENTS. AND WITH
THAT WE HAVE- TWO WITNESSES
OFFERING TESTIMONY- THE FIRST IS
A STELLAR OCEAN WITH- THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU AND WE
HAVE SHOULD ATTACH CHEF SENT ON
OF THE S. THE DIRECTOR OF
CULINARY OPERATIONS AND
INNOVATION AT THE UC- DAVIS
MEDICAL CENTER- SO. THANK YOU
FOR READING- I LIKE TO THINK
MANY FOR THE UP TO TESTIFY MY
NAME IS SANTANA DHEAS- DIRECTOR
CORNER OPERATIONS AND INNOVATION
AND EXECUTIVE CHEF- FOR A FOOD
NUTRITION SERVICES AT UC DAVIS
HEALTH. HOWEVER I'M HERE AS A
PRIVATE CITIZEN AND MY TESTIMONY
DOES NOT REPRESENT THE VIEWS OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA- SO
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS- WITHIN
HAVE THE HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY
HAVE HELPED INTRODUCE A TRUE.
CALIFORNIA FOCUSED FOOD
PROCUREMENT PROGRAM MAKING UC
DAVIS HEALTH. FOOD NUTRITION
SERVICES AND NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED LEADER FOR
SUSTAINABLE FOOD WITHIN HEALTH
CARE PER PRACTICE GREEN HEALTH
AND HEALTH CARE WITH HIGHER
HEALTH CARE WITHOUT HARM
GUIDELINES. THIS TRANSITION
COMES FROM MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH LARGE SCALE FOOD
OPERATIONS SUCH AS HOTELS AND
OPENING UP SPORTS VENUES LIKE
LEVI STADIUM GOLDEN ONE CENTER.
THAT THE TIME IS NOW FOR
PATIENTS TO RECEIVE QUALITY
HEALTHY AND NUTRITIOUS FOODS
THAT ARE SOURCED FROM THE BOUNTY
OF OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES REGIONS
OF THE STATE. OPERA THE CITY.
UNIVERSITY OF NEW YORK- THE CAME
OUT- AND MARCH THIRTIETH WITH
THE REPORT THAT SAID TITLED HOW
FOOD AND DIET IMPACT THE
TREATMENT OF DISEASE. THEY FOUND
THAT QUOTE THERE IS OVERWHELMING
EVIDENCE DEMONSTRATING THE
IMPACT OF FOOD AND DIET ON
HEALTH. SPECIFICALLY AMONG FOOD
RELATED DISEASES WHILE DIET HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO CAUSE DISEASE
IT ALSO. IS CAPABLE OF BUILDING
MAINTAINING AND RESTORING HEALTH
. THIS FARM HOSPITAL PILOT BILL
WILL BRIDGE THE GAP BETWEEN
TRADITIONAL MEDICINE AND USE THE
FOOD AS MEDICINE FOCUSING ON
PREVENTION AND TREATMENT OF
DISEASE ALL WHILE SUPPORTING A
CALIFORNIA FOOD AND AGRICULTURE.
THIS WOULD ALLOW AN
INSTITUTIONAL PROGRAM LIKE THE
HOSPITAL WHERE I RESIDE TO
REMOVE UNNECESSARY ADDITIVES AND
PRESERVATIVES FROM MENUS WHILE
USING NUTRITION AS A GUIDELINE
OF VALUES TO PROMOTE CLEAN AND
HEALTHY FOOD FOR OUR PATIENTS.
THIS IS NOT A NEW PRACTICE IT IS
TIME TO INCREASE THE ADOPTION
WITHIN THE HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY.
ANCHOR INSTITUTIONS CAN
INFLUENCE PURCHASING PRACTICES
BY CREATING THE DEMAND FOR
AGRICULTURE AND KEEP FARMS A
FLOAT AN EXAMPLE THIS EFFORT
WOULD BE HOW THE UC DAVIS
HEALTH. FOOD SYSTEM WAS ABLE TO
AVOID. MANY OF THE NATIONAL FOOD
SYSTEM SHOCKS EXPERIENCED DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND THE SUPPLY
CHAIN WOES BY SOURCING MANY OF
THE FOODS OF THE PROGRAM FROM
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS ALSO YOU'LL THIS STRONG
RESILIENCY FOR A COMMUNITY
WITHIN REACH WITH RESPECT TO
JOBS AND HAVING A MULTITUDE OF
POSITIVE RIPPLE EFFECTS. THIS%
PILOT WILL PROVIDE VALUABLE
INFORMATION TO HELP BUILD THESE
FOOD PROGRAMS INTO EVERYDAY
OPERATIONS HOSPITALS HAVE THE
CHANCE TO WORK WITH YOUNG
PATIENTS WITHIN PEDIATRIC
PROGRAMS AND EDUCATE THE YOUTH.
USING FOOD AS MEDICINE HOSPITAL
SHOULD ACT AS A TEACHING
FACILITY USING FOOD AS A CORE
COMPONENT COMPONENT OF HEALTH
AND AB TWENTY FIVE OR- TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED. WILL HELP US. M.
GET THAT MUCH CLOSER. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
AND I REQUEST THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. A GOOD AFTERNOON
TAYLOR SOME OF THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU WE SUPPORT AND AB
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED- CALIFORNIA
GROWS THE SAFEST AND HEALTHIEST
PRODUCTS IN THE WORLD I THINK
ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT HELPING
SECURE POPULATION SHOULD BE
PRIVY TO THESE AMAZING LOCAL
BENEFITS- TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
WOULD HELP CALIFORNIA'S FARMS
AND RANCHERS BY ESTABLISHING
MODELS FOR LOCAL FOOD
PROCUREMENT. AND HOPEFULLY BE
ABLE TO BE REPLICATED OVER
MULTIPLE LARGER SCALE
INSTITUTIONS AND HOPEFULLY THE
STATE TO MAKE SOME- INVESTED
PROCUREMENT IN CALIFORNIA
GROUND- THIS CAN CREATE AND
ENHANCE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FARMERS THAT DEAL WITH
INCREDIBLY HIGH PRODUCTION COSTS
LOST MARKETS FROM CODED. OR
CURRENT PORT ISSUE THESE HEARD
MR FONG SPEAK ON AN
INTERNATIONAL COMPETITION
LIMITED RESOURCES- OR HOPEFULLY
NEW AND BEGINNING FARMERS AND
RANCHERS THEY CAN FIND NEW
MARKETS AND NEW OPPORTUNITIES
AND INSTITUTIONAL PURCHASERS-
ALL THIS IN TRYING TO NAVIGATE
THE INCREDIBLY COMPLEX BIDDING
PROCESS THAT- ALL INSTITUTIONS
HAVE SO FOR THESE REASONS WE
SUPPORT TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HEARING.
PART THANK YOU- THEY'RE STILL
REGISTERED OPPOSITION ON FILE IS
THERE ANY SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM. C. NINE
AND WE'VE JUST CHECKED WITH THE
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR THERE'S
NONE IN Q. SHALL ON THE STREETS
FOR NUMBER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE
SECRETARY OVER THERE. ON AB
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED ARAMBULA
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
HEALTH COMMITTEE CHAIR RIVAS HI
RIVAS AYE MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. FLORA FLORA I
AGREE GRAY I IRWIN- AYE JONES
SAWYER LEVINE. LEVINE IBM TO
WALK BE APPROVED WHILE I WOULD.
WOULD I. THE BILL IS OUT IN SO-
REMAINING ITEMS IS ARE
CONSECUTIVE ASSEMBLY BILLS TWO
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAY AND IS AB TWO FOUR ONE FOUR
BY MATHIS IS THERE A MOTION.
BECAUSE THAT IS OUR SECOND. GET
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FOR CONSENT ITEMS CONSENT
CALENDAR. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE AB TWENTY FOUR
FOURTEEN WHICH WILL BE DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS AND AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH WILL
ALSO BE DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
AFTER REVENGE HI RIVAS I MATHIS
MATHIS AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I. FLORA
. LARA I AGREE GRAY I IRWIN-
IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER LEVINE.
LEVINE IDEA WOULD WANT ME
VALLAPUDUA I WOULD. WOULD I.
OKAY SO NOW WE WERE MOVE ON TO
ITEM SEVEN SOME THE BILL TO FOR
ONE TO BE A BY THEIR MOTION-
SECOND. COMMERCIALS I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR SOME OF BILL TWO FOUR ONE
TWO. ON AB TWO FOUR ONE TWO
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE SURE RIVAS HI
RIVAS AYE MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE FLORA. FLORA I
AGREE GRAY I IRWIN IRWIN AYE
JONES SAWYER LEVINE LEVINE IDEA
PUT OFF THE APPROVAL I WOULD.
WOOD I BILL IS OUT AND SO-
BECAUSE WE JUMPED THE GUN A BIT
ON THE PREVIOUS TWO BILLS I WHEN
WE GOT INTO THIS NEW ROOM WE
HAVE TO TAKE UP- WE NEED A
MOTION FOR SOME THE BILL ONE SIX
SEVEN EIGHT MOST FONG SECOND
MOTION SECOND- AND SECTARIAN
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. ON AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT MOTION IS
DUE PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR RIVAS HI TERRY OF US I'D
MATHIS MATHIS AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I. FLORA.
FLORA I AGREE. GRAY I IRWIN-
IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER LEVINE
LEVINE IV A PUT OFF BE A GOOD
WHILE I WOULD. WHAT I. THE BILL
IS OUT AND THEN OUR FINAL ITEM
NUMBER FOR SOME OF THE BILL ONE
SEVEN SEVEN THREE THEIR MOTION.
SO MOTION SECOND MAGIC TRICK
THIS COUPLE. ON AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY THREE MOTION AS DO
PASSED TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE CHAIR RIVAS HI RIVAS I
AM MATHIS MATHIS AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. FLORA. LARA I
AGREE GREAT I IRWIN- IRWIN AYE
JONES SAWYER LEVINE LEVINE IDEA
PUT OFF ME VALLAPUDUA I WOULD
WOULD I. OKAY BILLS OUT WITH
THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK
EVERYBODY. THE STATE OF TEXAS
REACTION BECAUSE- COULD NOT BE
CONSIDERED. SAY. EXPECT.